has already happened to Tokyo will
happen to every Japanese City for Japan
the stock market on Monday sinking to
its lowest close in over two years five
million Japanese lost their jobs Japan's
Japan
on December 29 1989 Japan's stock market
index reached a value of 38 957 points
from there the index saw a decent
sell-off of about 30 percent over the
next couple of months not much was
thought of this at the time given that
there was a global market sell-off so
most assumed that this was just a
routine bear Market but the bear Market
quickly became much more painful within
nine months after the peak the index
would crash all the way down to 19 760
points which correlates to about a 50
sell-off by this point it was clear that
this was no longer just a routine bear
Market this was now a Monumental crash
like the.com crash or the 2008 financial
recession that people would remember for
decades fortunately from there it seemed
like the bottom was in the index would
bounce a solid 37 percent and no new
lows would be formed for well over a
year but if you invested during this
time period you would soon be regretting
it because the index would make yet
another leg down by the end of 1992 only
a total of 63 percent if I was a
Japanese citizen during this time period
I would have almost definitely been all
in every month I'd probably be chucking
my entire paycheck at the index thinking
that it was just a matter of time until
this thing recovered and that's what it
seemed like for a very long time for the
next eight years the index would bounce
between 13 000 and the 23 000 points and
seemingly build a massive base surely
this was the base that was required to
support the next bull market but the
exact opposite would take place once
again at the turn of the century the.com
bubble would have burst which pushed
down the index all the way down to 7 500
points this was no longer just a stock
market crash this was a full-on stock
market depression comparable to that of
the Great Depression but even this was
is not the bottom the real bottom
wouldn't come till November of 2008 when
the index crashed a total of 82 percent
since then the index has recovered
substantially growing over 300 percent
but even today we have yet to surpass
the all-time high that was set nearly 33
years ago and that's with inflation and
with the global economy entering yet
another downturn it doesn't seem like
Japan will be making any new all-time
highs in the imminent future to make
things worse this doesn't just apply to
the Japanese stock market either if we
switch over to the real estate market
we'll see that a very similar trend has
materialized after Decades of growth the
real estate market peaked out in 1991
before crashing 50 and even today the
market is down about 30 percent if we
take a look at Japan's GDP numbers we'll
see a slightly better picture instead of
going straight down and not recovering
their GDP has more or less gone sideways
for 30 years but for a country like
Japan that was once universally known
for Innovation and progress this too is
disappointing so what in the world
happened to Japan and is this what's
eventually in store for America
even though the Japanese stock market
didn't Peak out till the end of the 80s
the seeds for Devastation had been
planted decades earlier it all started
right after World War II the war had
destroyed Japan in every sense
physically economically mentally
spiritually you name it the Japanese
empire had diverted almost everything
they had to the war effort for several
years and all they had to show for it
was pure Devastation and to put salt on
their wound there were nearly a million
American soldiers occupying their
largest cities but while their morale
was at all-time lows something was
changing behind the scenes the reason
America was occupying Japan was to make
sure that Japan didn't pull a quick one
and start another conflict in other
words America was basically trying to
babysit Japan but the Dynamics of this
relationship rapidly evolved into being
a partnership you see it it didn't take
long for America to realize that Japan
wasn't the biggest threat the biggest
threat was actually the Soviet Union and
it was in America's best interest to
have a partner in in the East the only
two viable candidates for this role were
of course Japan and China and given that
China was barreling towards a Communist
Revolution America had to choose Japan
so over the next several years they
worked with the Japan to establish a
western capitalist economy general
Douglas MacArthur worked with Japanese
leaders to implement a new Constitution
that prioritized the limited government
free and fair elections private property
and individual liberties they also eased
off on the ridiculous income tax that
went up to 86 percent these changes set
up Japan for success and after the
Americans left in the early 1950s Japan
was after the races between 1950 and
1973 Japan would grow at twice the rate
of Western Europe and at two and a half
times the rate of America during the
1960s this resulted in their stock
market exploding a mind-boggling six
thousand one hundred percent while this
is no doubt extraordinary one caveat
that we should note is that Japan was
growing from nearly 0 0. so they had a
lot more Headroom to grow than
traditional Western countries and such
growth was obviously not sustainable
indefinitely but Japan wanted to make it
indefinite and this is what would
eventually seal their fate
as you might have guessed the main way
in which Japan tried to keep the growth
going was through money printing but we
can't blame them too much because the
growth wasn't the only reason that Japan
was printing money Japan's choice to
print money was actually overseen it and
backed by all of the most prominent
Western countries through an agreement
called The Plaza Court the Plaza Court
was an agreement between the G5 Nations
and it was actually designed to help
Japan and Germany you see it while the
Japanese and the German economies had
grown exponentially since World War II
there was still a massive trade
imbalance between these countries and
the United States the main reason for
this was the rapid appreciation of the
US dollar in the 1980s after a decade of
high inflation in the 1970s the U.S
finally put their foot down and the
jacked upgrades all the way to 20
percent while this move was effective in
cooling down inflation and helping the
dollar appreciate 47.9 percent this move
also had some unintended consequences
like the trade imbalance a strong dollar
meant that it was extremely expensive
for foreign countries like Japan and
Germany to buy U.S goods and for
companies with a large International
presence this was terrible news so they
decided to Lobby Congress to weaken the
US dollar which eventually resulted in
the plaza Accord instead of focusing on
growth the U.S agreed to focus on
addressing their budget deficit
meanwhile Germania and Japan agreed to
cut taxes lower interest rates and of
course print money to hopefully
stimulate their economies this planet
actually worked out surprisingly well as
the US dollar fell as much as 25.8
percent within the next two years this
newly eliminated the trade deficit
between the U.S and the Germany but the
deficit between Japan and the US was
still non-negligible nonetheless the US
did not want to overdo the weakening of
the dollar so they would Implement
another Accord called a Lube record this
Accord was meant to essentially reverse
all of the policies set forth by the
Plaza Court and stabilize exchange rates
but even though the Lou record was
signed rather proactively it seems that
Japan had already overdone the economic
loosening as as a prices had gone way
too far
a lot of people like to claim it that
the overvaluation of the U.S stock
market in 2020 and 2021 was the worst
that we've ever seen But in reality that
was nothing in comparison to the
Japanese stock market in the late 1980s
take the price to earnings ratio for
example the median for the S P 500 over
the past 90 years is 14.9 in 2020 and
2021 this ratio of reached levels of 35
to 40. so there's no doubt that the U.S
stock market was overvalued and it's
just now starting to return to normal
levels but do you know what levels the
Japanese stock market reached well it
reached PE ratios of 60. for perspective
the us only reached PE ratios of 44 even
during the.com bubble now the US did
reach PE ratios as high as 123 during
the financial crisis but that wasn't due
to asset valuations getting super high
it was actually due to corporate
earnings falling off a cliff which
screwed up the ratio this wasn't what
was happening in Japan they straight up
just had a PE ratio of 60. this meant
that their stock market would have to
crash at 75 percent just to return to
normal levels a very similar Trend was
beginning to appear within the real
estate market as well by 1985 Tokyo's
commercial districts had already reached
full capacity this meant that if you
wanted a piece of the pie you had to buy
it from someone else and given that the
economy was booming it there wasn't very
many people who were willing to sell
this quickly resulted in buyers becoming
desperate combine this with record low
interest rates and it didn't take long
for Real Estate to turn into one massive
bidding war in 1984 one square meter of
land in Tokyo's commercial District cost
five thousand six hundred dollars by
1985 this Rose to 7958 per square meter
as you can see prices were already
skyrocketing and when you're through the
plaza accorded into the mix things went
parabolic by 1986 a single square meter
of commercial land cost 20 35
000 by 1987 this Rose to forty five
thousand dollars and by 1989 we were
talking about an eye-watering 218
000 per square meter for my fellow
metrically disabled peers this
translates to twenty thousand dollars
per square feet certain parts of Tokyo
had literally appreciated 40x in a
matter of five years and at this point
it was just a matter of time until
evaluations collapsed to make things
worse Japan was also starting to undergo
a demographics crisis as countries
develop birth rates tend to go down and
eventually they become so low that the
country is no longer self-sustaining
this has actually happened to the us as
well but thanks to America's relatively
generous immigration policies the
country has been able to continue
growing Japan's immigration policies
however have never been as lenient as
Americas and many even go as far as
claiming that Japan's immigration
policies are self-destructive and when
you combine declining demographics with
ludicrous asset valuations Japan is what
you get
this Monumental decline in Japan was
initially dubbed the Lost decade but it
has since been revised to be named the
last decades and honestly there is no
true quoting it Japan's economy has
stagnated for three decades and with the
current economic decline it seems highly
likely that this will turn into four
decades Japan's financial situation
doesn't make things any better either
Japan is the most indebted country in
the world relative to their GDP coming
in at a painful 237 percent even the us
with our ridiculous 31 trillion dollars
in debt is only at 125 percent but
honestly none of that is even Japan's
biggest concern by far Japan's biggest
concern is through reigning demographics
28.7 of Japan's population is over the
age of 65 and only 12.3 percent are
under the age of 15. so in terms of
young ambitious Souls they don't have
very many we should also mention that
their migrant population has also been
on a decline and without a positive
change in their demographic profile or
some sort of innovative miracle I just
don't see how Japan can enter another
highly prosperous period anytime soon as
for how this applies to the US given
that our markets are almost back to
normal levels and given that our
immigration numbers are still relatively
strong I don't think we're headed into
some sort of 30 to 40 year long bear
Market but that's just what I think when
do you think this current economic
decline will come to a close comment
that down below also drop a like if you
hope that your country doesn't end up
like Japan and of course consider
checking out our Discord Community
suggested video ideas and consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on the next
one
foreign
[Music]